uh good afternoon this is ee 380 at
stanford
with ted nelson
a friend of
50 years almost
um from
the great state of new jersey
he has the same decorative uh taste that
i do with the cardboard boxes across the
back
of the room and uh lots of information
ted is uh a um
well i don't know what he is he's not a
computer scientist
but he is a
philosopher of the mind i think
he knows how people think
and he has for years fought for
computer systems which
support
how humans think
and uh for that we can all thank him
uh he's um
one of the greats
you can't say much more than that
hi i'm ted nelson i always start that
way
i'm honored to be here at virtual
stanford and my thanks to dennis allison
for inviting me
i'll talk a while and then take
questions we'll have to quit at your 5
pm chart
okay
the standard story of my life which
you'll read in wikipedia is that i
simply coined the word hypertext one of
various words i've coined hypertext
hypermedia transclusion dildonics
enchilada data structure but i just
remembered that i invented hypertext
which i had forgotten
now it is
unseemly and suspicionable to be making
this claim now
but you'll forgive the irregularity of
an old man's memory
this narrative involves a multi-year
timeline which i'll make clear as we go
along
first item on the timeline
january 23rd 1950 a cover of time
magazine i was in eighth grade
which caricatured a computer for in the
mark iii naval computer wearing a naval
officer's hat and eyeing along tape
the caption was can man build a superman
i read the article and couldn't
understand how computer processes went
beyond numbers
timeline jump
to 1959 when i got out of college
when i graduated my father offered me a
career as a hollywood actor the whole
nine yards agent at sag card and all he
was a director and could do that
and i now regret that i didn't take that
offer
but instead when i popped out of
swarthmore in 1959 i thought myself all
too clever able to see farther and
faster than most and i hope to find or
found
some new field that hadn't been invented
yet
so i went to graduate school to find out
what i've missed as an undergraduate
timeline jump to 1960.
at harvard in the fall of 1960 i took a
computer course i had wanted to know
what the hell the computer was since
that baffling cover of time magazine in
1950
i was astounded they had been lying
computers were not mathematical they
were all-purpose machines they could
hold text and you could put screens on
them interactive screens
that was clear in the brochures from
digital equipment corporation
interactive screams
i was a movie maker i could see it once
with that mint i predicted in 1960 that
the interactive screen would be the new
home of the human race
was i wrong
uh but there were only a few
interactive screens in the country and i
had never seen one
i started collecting the brochures on
interactive graphic machines from
digital equipment they didn't claim to
be selling computers they called them
program data processors or pdps
and i believe i told people in 1960 the
interactive screen will be the new home
of the human race
was i wrong
but nobody could understand what i was
talking about
this i thought was my sword in the stone
my door to greatness i was going to be
the ceo and figurehead of the personal
computer revolution
i would found the field of personal
computing with a company called general
creative inc of which i would be ceo and
figurehead
in fact i basically
invented the concept of apple and steve
jobs
but it was too early the real steve
johnson was only five years old
and i never found my wozniac
still i plunged ahead in 1960 with my
plan for great general creative i would
open a word processing coffee house
right away in harvard square
my 1960 sketch for that
coffee house is on the internet archive
on the ted nelson upload page as well as
other notes from 1960 for general
creative
my coffeehouse pitch must have been
great a fellow grad student named graham
gibbert was going to invest
ten thousand dollars
but thank god i didn't take his money or
go any further
i see that somebody named graham gibbert
co-authored two books on group sociology
that's all i can find out but i guess it
was the same guy
so much for 1960.
then stuff happened i got married taught
sociology advancement
timeline jumped to 1965. my courses are
under control and i publish a lot of
articles about hypertext about movie
editing by computer about what would
later be called cgi i was trying to
develop a cgi system i called phantasm
along with a lot of other designs too
many of the designs
so in 1965 i published papers on
phantasm on movie editing by computer
and on hypertext
my biggest hit in 1965 was my paper on
hypertext for the acm national
conference
i believe that most of the computer
scientists in the world may have been
there it was still possible at that time
and my final slide said change change
change exclamation point
the applause was thunderous
afterward bob taylor came up to me and
asked if i'd heard of douglas engelbart
in california
that dude did text systems i've resolved
to meet this king fellow bob taylor was
at that time doug engelbart's financial
sponsor at darpa which was at the time
called defense advancement for research
projects
of america or something
timeline jump to next year 1966 and i'm
assistant to the president of harcourt
brace in the world
wild bill yavana which himself
i'm trying it's a publishing company a
notable publishing company
i'm assistant to what i'm uh reporting
wild billy abolish himself i'm trying to
get him to buy a pdp graphics machine he
budgeted at 50 000 for the year
and in that fateful 1966
while bill ivanovich and i
fly out together to california
ivanovich's company harcourt sells text
textbooks so ivanovich wants to meet
with richard atkinson yes at stanford
he's a big name in programming his
construction in the meeting i tried to
tell richard atkinson about hypertext he
bellows or so i recall
we don't know how to do that yet
thinking i meant computer mint
computer-assisted instruction where the
student has a conversation with the
computer
from his inability to hear me i thought
richard atkinson was the most pig-headed
individual i had ever met
some years later i noted with interest
that richard atkinson had become
president of the entire university of
california perhaps pigheadedness is what
it takes
anyway because of the trip with wild
bill yobanovic there i was in california
in 66 so i went to see engelbart
and he was the nicest possible guy
i got the whole demo from him the
legendary great demo he gave two years
later to an audience in california you
can watch it online it's called the
mother of all demos
it's an hour
and and he begins by
being very modest and saying he's going
to talk through the microphone and
you're going to see stuff on the screen
and he types with one hand and uses the
mouse for the other
his name engelbart was norwegian i later
mentioned the name to my grandfather my
grandfather said oh yes engelbart
angel's beard
apparently norwegian angels have beards
so engelbart showed me his hypertext
jump
but like all his functions it required a
keyboard input
you had to memorize keyboard
instructions
so it wasn't what i thought of as a
smooth functioning literary medium you
had to learn commands
so
here is the simple
command list
for angle bar system
with about 20 commands
it was two-sided in the original so it's
on the internet archive
20 commands on each page
that you had to learn
timeline jump to the next year 1967.
that was the expo 67 in montreal
i went to see the movies they had a 360
degree movie
vertical screen a 360 uh movie that you
ducked under to be fully surrounded by
360 degrees of movie a vertical screen
with a horizontal screen and a movie
with a choose your own ending i couldn't
get in but i talked to the producer raju
shinshara who explained to me that it
was not a great carpet of choices as it
seemed to be but always a two-way choice
leading to what would turn out to be the
next two-way choice so it's very
trickily constructed to have only
pairwise
jumps that were always the same on the
next one
okay
timeline jump to next year in 1968.
i've been fired by wild bill yovanovich
the ibm salesman had won keeping rival
equipment out of harcourt and getting
rid of me as well
that's about when my former friend van
damme
came to our host house in poughkeepsie
and invited me oh so warmly
to come to brown and to quote try out
your crazy ideas unquote
now
bendam and i have been macho
acquaintances at swarthmore while most
people play frisbee with plastic discs
about 11 inch discs
frisbee had just arrived in spring of 57
i think and so it was a year and a half
later that i graduated somehow i'd
gotten hold my senior year of steel beer
trays about 18 inches in diameter and
van damme and i would hurl and chase
them at great distances of hundreds of
yards that was the extent of our
friendship but it was cordial
so
i started to commute to brown
and for two years drove back and forth
at my own expense
burning up my savings of i think at 2100
thinking i would get some reward of
thanks
whether but there had been no
negotiation let that be listed
so for two years i commuted to brown in
1968 1968-9 creating the ags system yes
i rented cars for the purpose and i
rented a room in the graduate dormitory
van damme was certainly no longer a
friend his cordiality turned to venom
he treated me with incredible insult and
scorn the same way he treated his lowest
rank assistance or quote schleps
i was cordial to him but he did not
return it i invited him to dinner no
response
i conjecture that this nasty streak was
acquired in his boyhood which i've heard
was in a japanese prison camp in the
dutch east indies but i can't confirm
that
so i was hard working driving back and
forth unpaid constantly insulted and
never thanked with even a letter i later
asked the acm for an ethics hearing on
my treatment at brown but by then the
matter was much too far in the past
okay so my work at brown in 1968 in
1969.
vandam had the expensive the super
expensive graphics system from ibm
millions of dollars worth unlike the low
price screens from digital equipment
i worked with the main programmer
stephen carmody
harmony and i implemented the
highlighted span of text which when
clicked
clicked
caused a jump to another page i'll
repeat that here's some text on the
screen a certain part is differentiated
so it looks different
and invites you to click on it
i called it a link
an author could highlight a portion of
text and a reader could click on it
whereupon another page would replace it
that worked fine
not to be upstaged by my link van damme
created the quote branch
a multiple choice point that does not
survive
in this project i also invented the back
button
i think it was carmody who said quote
users will never understand that
i said trust me
people have asked me which black buttons
i invented all of them i say believing
they derived from the oneness
okay confirmation i believe this whole
story can be confirmed by the
distinguished san francisco attorney
terry gross
who as an undergraduate was part of the
team
graduated with a mat with a major in
computer science
so that is the story i implemented the
link as we now know it
and who gets the credit why of course
tim berners-lee
timeline jumped at whenever
tim is a great guy i've argued with him
at length in his home in massachusetts i
gave his wife my art deco wristwatch
when she admired it
some other timeline jump tim and i also
argued in a bar in tokyo
timeline jumped to maybe 2019 in san
francisco at the internet archive i told
tim that his main achievement as i see
it was to unify all the different
servers on the internet for the
consistent addressing scheme the url
despite their different operating
systems which is why a space is
represented by percent 20. don't ask me
more about that the rest would have
happened if you once given the url
hypertext would have happened
and he agreed with me
so i will stop there
and take questions
in any case uh when you're meeting with
engelbart did you have any uh
uh
any insight who's speaking by the way
who's gonna guess
i'm up here
oh it says you're muted but apparently
you're not
probably not
uh in any case
um
in your um
in your meeting with angel bart did you
learn anything that was uh really
surprising for you
no
much of it was as i had imagined of
course i was immediately converted to
the mouse
but the uh
the the keyboard that you'd have to
learn well um
that that was that was a that was
definitely a thresh
a hard threshold and the many commands
that were required
were a considerable problem
so
i i showed you the i showed you the
small
command structure now here's here's here
is the big one
the
quick reference
[Laughter]
with about 70 commands on this page and
70 commands on that page
so agave you see
had this interesting way of putting it
he said
it's easy to learn to ride a tricycle
but you can't get it far enough
get very far
whereas it's harder to learn to a
bicycle to ride a bicycle but you can
get much farther on a bicycle
however learning
170 commands or whatever the number you
want to say
was not like learning to ride a bicycle
because once you learn to ride a bicycle
it's easy it's got its own swoop
but those those many many commands
didn't have a swoop you had to memorize
them but he imagined
that this was a threshold
people could be expected
to navigate
and and and this this was
his fundamental misunderstanding did you
try to use the paddles and the foot
paddles
as well
yes he had a handset which had eight
eight buttons on it but it was a chord
keyboard
and you could write various things into
the chord keyboard i didn't see it yeah
and also there was a foot one as well
but it was less uh less
less
elegant i actually have a a an engelbart
key set with the five paddles and the uh
it's been
adapted with a with a usb
interface so if i want if i ever want to
start learning to use it that'd be great
although i think it only types capital
right
so out there is there anybody else who
has questions or am i the only
interested person here
okay there are a couple questions in
chat
um
i'll read them
do you have any ideas for a user
interface for bi-directional hyperlinks
other than a list of links to the page
in particular there are some good
options for making bi-directional links
visible in a work written by a single
person
the moderator can read this question
well
talking about interfaces
is just talk without a whiteboard and
without
so the answer is yeah sure
but we're not but but it's there there
are many possibilities depends on what
what sorts of gimmicks you're using are
you using a mouse are you using
a track pad
but
how it would appear there are many
possibilities but
i wouldn't i wouldn't go into them in a
conversation
one of the other
attendees says what would you have
preferred
be done differently
to how the w3c implemented hyperdex
w3c did not implement it
tim
implemented
from then on it was this juggernaut that
he's writing
so
uh once once you have that juggernaut in
place all you can do is add
the mess that is html
and so
and and and
i hate it
well
you know
some years ago you worked well you
worked for a long time on the center of
the system which is a
different approach to uh
to the uh
representation of hypertext is this work
that continues
xanadu has had many many incarnations as
i i tried to leap from
possibility to possibility
i'm not actively working on it now
the
version
we programmed in 1969 with the dream
team was absolutely fabulous
and if i hadn't screwed up in 1988
and
when mark complained i demoted roger
and instead of trying to finish what
roger had done mark tried to
rebuild it completely differently and
after four years
autodesk cut him off
so if i hadn't demoted roger on mark's
complaint
it would have been finished
within the in fact
time horizon roger had predicted and we
would have had our own
version
not to say it would have been the only
system
but it would have been a demonstration
it would have been one system of
indexing all kinds of pieces
of creating virtual documents with
visible links and transclusions
and assigning
a universal
address
to every character
uh good to see you then a long time ago
but i would like to
i know
i would like to ask you
if this screen is the limit for
the hypertext now i'm working in outer
space
what kind of technologies you you
imagine we can use
in our street i mean i'm working with
space agencies what
what what do you think we can envision
on
on new technologies and new
interfaces
on
i mean if the the space is the limit i
mean the
the sky's the limit
and and the screen is the limit
i mean what metaphor
can you vision
for these new
technologies that can be developed on
these new environments and
abundantly what new technologies
i'm asking if you imagine one
no i mean a screen is a screen is a
fundamental concept
and it's not going to change we may have
better screens we have better ways of
flipping amongst them and and new styles
of
of interaction
but two dimensions will be with us
forever
of course
we'll have the three-dimensional
headsets too but uh you can't always get
that
you can't count on having
walking around with your head in a
three-dimensional
gadget
nice
good to hear need to hear you what did
you do after your university
i lost your track
there you were teaching at the
government
school or something like that
you're asking about 60 years of what i
did well no 40 years of what i did
i did a lot of different things i taught
a number of different places
published many articles
excellent
so thank you
good to see you
wow there's a real hot group here really
lively
i think i think it's the the technology
is for many people still a bit of an
intimidation
um
so
could you summarize kind of the advances
over engelbart's uh system that
you made here
advances i made over individuals oh you
did that that year
yeah that you you made your system made
over engelbart system
engelbart
had a cosmic system that did 150 things
okay
xanadu has always dealt with connected
documents
so that's
one small part
of the hundred and that's that's two out
of 150 things that engelbart system did
and we had our own way of doing it our
own
internals
and again i'm referring to the canonical
system of 1969 with the dream team
yeah
uh we had our own internals our own
addressing our own universal addressing
scheme
which was going to unite all the servers
in the same way not the same way but
much
just as tim berners-lee united all the
servers with the url we were like we
were going to unite all the servers with
a comparable address
hi i have a question speaking as a hard
hardware engineer uh
what was it like running and developing
all this on vintage 1969 hardware
we weren't running it on 1969 hardware
we were designing it on blackboard
oh i see
we then obtained
probably the first
unix system that was available to the
public
i forget who the manufacturer was
and and
and
roger
worked hard translating that code he
called it xu88 now remember we designed
this in 99 we called it xu88 because he
figured it would take until 1988 to get
it working
and he worked on it
all
those years
and in 1988
if i hadn't
demoted mark when roger
demanded roger when mark complained we
would have had it running
and what year did you get the first unix
system
whenever it was available
uh
something like
1972 i'm not sure okay
okay
the unix systems were available
to nonprofits we were not a non-profit
so we had to buy one
well anyways it was assumed that the
nonprofit had its own hardware
but then they could get they would get
the
unix would be free
somewhere somewhere in this uh household
or in this
complex of buildings i have a brochure
called
the unix
programming the unix programmers console
an introduction
and i believe it was the first
write-up
that what's his name and what's his name
who created unix said they called it a
programmer's console not a time sharing
system it had followed multics you see
and multics
tried to put
all the different
functions
into different programs
whereas unix have this ad the much more
straightforward notion of a fundamental
kernel
and then individual what you call it
uh
that are that have been called by this
colonel to do particular things with
particular arguments
so i have a question ted yeah about i
know you yes
i have to point out that your book
computer lib and dream machines
depending on which way it was turned it
was one of the most influential books in
my life
about comparable to the whole earth
catalog for computing
and
i really think you should revive that
book
uh it it if it's not correct it is
available now oh it is okay go to
nullswag.com
you can get them either shrink wrapped
in a recent printing
or if you're if you're some kind of a
fetishist you can get original
first first editions for like much more
i think i think the shrink wrap costs a
hundred dollars now and the and the the
your first editions are more i don't run
that
i still have one of course
right but anyway nelswag.com is is
selling various stuff of mine
i get a cut
i hope so
cool
yeah the the uh
the thing that
the most amazing stuff that you produced
over the years in any case
what you did is you did a
bunch of
books that were inspiring
about how things ought to work and how
they ought to look and how they ought to
do
um the computer science center was hard
because we'd never done it before and
a lot of times
what you wanted was not known we didn't
know how to do it
but
over time we've gotten closer but we're
still a long way from that because you
move the ball forward every time you
have the opportunity
but it's it's interesting as i said you
weren't a computer scientist
you were
who says i wasn't a computer scientist i
would say that you're not a computer
scientist you're a step above a computer
scientist computer scientists work with
the little parts of the computer you
actually work with the way people use
them and think
i also did a lot of internal design
many different versions of xanadu in
terms of
uh data structures and so on oh i
understand that so if that's not
computer science then
what is that is computer science but the
thing that has always impressed me about
your work
has been
that you articulated goals that would
were not obviously goals and you
got people to think about what they were
doing and how it worked and what the
relationships
of things were in ways that
the normal computer scientists never did
and it was uh it was a
a big thing for you i think it was
certainly a big thing for a lot of us
and you know i think i think you know
you're
it puts you in the in the forefront of
the computer's computer people
from the uh
from the from the you know 60s on
and you know it's just
a lot of people
are really i think unaware of how
influential and significant the work
you've been done
has been
and so
go read the books
start out with computer lit and or one
of the others and but computer live is
the book that that inspired so many
people
when i was running the people's computer
company
and computer k lib came out it was for
us a bestseller for quite a long time
and um we had
to deal with the fact that it was
self-published and
you know the uh the supply chain was not
necessarily great but
it um
i was screwed by my distributors sold 50
000 college copy didn't say csf
yeah
well
it's nonetheless you inspired a
generation of people who learned about
computers and then built things with
them what was most what is most
interesting retroactively about computer
lib i think is the number of different
areas and specialties
that i mentioned which were surprising
to people in other specialties
so so it was a it was a panoramic view
of a whole lot of stuff that wasn't
available anywhere else
that's right
and it it was in the same general
stylistic category as the whole earth
catalog and
a whole bunch of other
documents of the time which
basically laid out technology and
people's
uh
kitchen table and they got to pick what
they wanted to play with and what they
didn't
and
uh
they were heady times
and
you know
it
it still strikes me as being
very strange the pcc we were able to
sell computer time to fifth graders at
25 cents an hour on a basic shared
system
basic
uh in a little uh work area that was uh
filled with uh books and papers and
games to play and that sort of thing
um but those people went on to become
the uh systems programmers of our time
and
you know the secret in some sense to the
uh to the silicon valley was that we had
a whole bunch of people who learned
about
computers and got thinking about things
very early in their lives
pre-pre-high school
pretty nice
okay hi ted um so i'm from the strategy
field and uh i wanted to ask your your
viewers in the strategy field what is
that
uh it's from the business school
strategic management ah because i took
strategy under tom shelling at harvard
you don't get anything
that's really magical
i i wanted to ask you about your your
view of the kind of in terms of
implementing xanadu and so forth
what do you think about the current
technology landscape in particular like
a a small number of very large
technology platforms seem to be
dominating
uh certainly in the business side and
actually you know a lot of the
conversation that's going on
even in the universities
so how would you go about who would you
work with who would you collaborate
uh how would you go about implementing
xanadu now when you have these energy
platforms
well okay let's let's let's talk about
what xanadu was in the in the xu 88
version
the notion of transclusion was
particularly
subtle
the idea being
that you could
bring in dynamically any part of any
other document
an author could require payments
now
people have accused me of wanting to
charge for everything not at all i
wanted to make it possible for people to
charge
so if you brought in something
that there was no charge for it appeared
immediately
if you translated something which
required payment this would become
evident
in
the
let's call it the browser of the user
and
the payment would have to be
made in order for that portion which was
translucent transcluded to come in
so this had this was a way and generally
lanier has praised it of handling
a
mashups
b
the the payment issue
which
everyone said oh that doesn't matter
and of course came to matter very much
later on
so it was an early solution it is an
early and elegant though now impossible
solution
to
a spectrum of issues the mashup
copyright
and
payment
my micropayment
beyond the kind of micropayments issue
it's just the kind of the way that
the large companies are kind of storing
data
um
seems very different from
what you had in mind
yeah everything's different
what can i say
yeah so okay
so how would you
navigate that you know
i give up i mean
it's just a it says an environment that
has to be lived in now
i'm not trying to i'm not trying to
build anything
so
ted how do you feel about the
the uh
sort of aggressive capture of
every piece of data you can possibly get
your hands on by
organizations
who is speaking now yes ah okay because
your your square isn't blinking or
anything
yeah the thing is that i'm post as well
and
zoom treats hosts specially
but in any case
what do you think of the of the
surveillance capitalism society that
we've created
uh
is this uh
it's certainly not the
something you created with your
model of how the world works but it's
certainly
warlords of what how the world works
but it has certainly had an impact on
on our society and how we
how things get dealt with
um
what am i supposed to say there it is
yeah yeah
no i'm just wondering whether you had
any thoughts as to what we might do
no
i'm just trying to survive in this mess
okay
other questions folks
i'll jump in for a second hi ted nice to
see you
have we met
we've met uh a number of times over the
years
um
i think the last time that we saw each
other was uh in the gate 5 parking lot
so uh and then there was a i think when
we first met i had lent you a uh
a u-matic video uh machine for one of
your demos or something anyway
we we we met like in 88 or 89 or
something i
met roger in palo alto and you know saw
you at autodesk a number of times and
um
so
i i
why i think fitz's question or you know
this this uh this issue of the
surveillance state you you devised a
this is maybe more of a commentary than
a question we'll find a question maybe
but you had a very uh democratized uh
model
that was very of the time and that was
um
and and and you're right i mean it's
just been co-opted it's just that's so
not
where the world is right now
but the the
the quality of foreshadowing that you
brought i'm just sort of ganging up with
dennis's comments i see you as the
direct descendant of van over
you you're really the second in line uh
uh to that
i called him up in kel in in the in the
cambridge once
and i i said i was interested in working
on his ideas but
but he sounded like an athletic coach so
that turned me off and i didn't call him
again yeah perhaps so nonetheless uh
intellectually conceptually you're of
that lineage and i very much see that
the
that the transclusion
mechanism it was
really uh
a log of links
uh and and sort of
the mechanism was was not of links it
was uh portions to be brought in
dynamically
but those portions
were
the history of those portions were
captured yes
the ownership of the portion of the
catherine not necessarily history
i see okay well because i was uh i i was
going to make a leap that there was some
sort of self-contained uh history of the
linkage and in that is a
kind of a foreshadowing of this whole
blocking
widget that people are so excited about
now but that's
maybe my a bridge in my mind no no one
else's anyway nice to see you when i saw
dennis's invitation uh uh for your uh
for your presentation today it's like i
gotta say hello to ted so
nice to see you i hope you're welcome
and i said i was gonna say some things
about engelbart i have a few remarks
prepared
first of all
um
the
first thing i want to say is that
after this is over
please
call up ted nelson's eulogy for doug
engelbart
because i worked very hard on that and
and
and
it tells
all too truly
what was important about doug's
life and work and how how betrayed he
felt
and
much of his work
so
i guess that's that's about i
there's so much to say about doug we had
many many hours of conversation and
they're all they're all on tape and he
has he gave us permission for them all
to be published so that could happen
sometime maybe
but he was a very very dear individual
because
his daughters thought he had alzheimer's
whereas in fact i think it was just
chemo brain he had cancer and had
had chemotherapy so his memory was very
poor
but aside from that
his personality was as angelic always as
possible
when it looked like we were going to
lose him marlene finally
agreed to marry me so that he could
perform the ceremony so
if you look on youtube
uh
the wedding ceremony where marlene and i
get married as as officiated by
by doug engelbart and his wife karen and
uh
i had an interesting anecdote which was
that doug told me that he was hired by
uh by a hewlett
of hewlett-packard
personally hired by hewlett
and uh and he said oh
but i want to work with computers and
hewlett said oh i'm sorry hewlett
packard will never have anything to do
with computers
okay
that was
then ted
yes hi
i can step in for a second
the all-american boy boy you're dating
yourself but we're dated both
um i was at the ai lab in
sri
at the time
all of this was going on
and
as you
i recall your visits
very well they were pretty whirlwind
visits as i recall
sri lanka at sri we shared the same
computer room i worked on shaky the
robot
which was right next to the to doug's
lab i read about shaking the robot in
life but i don't remember seeing it oh
well he was right there on
the other side of the computer room from
where they where we built the 10x and
where uh
doug had his terminal
you just want to comment you talked
about his approach to user interfaces
and he certainly did
want people to work to practice and do
all of these things
the analogy that i remember he gave if
you want to play tennis the only way
you'll be any good at it is practice
practice practice
and i'm a night owl and a software geek
and i worked on nls so i came into the
lab many times late at night because i
had some bright idea
usually at two in the morning
and i would go in and at the other end
of the lab there was doug engelbart
practicing
for
of with that the five key paddles on the
left side
the thumb was in a the next finger was b
those two fingers were c
right and we were supposed to learn all
of that he was the only you're counting
in binary if you know that
yes but he's he's the only one that ever
got that to work but he did it by
practicing for hours and hours
in late late hours in the uh
in the lab
but he all of your comments he was a
a formal phenomenal guy
i cherish the hours i had with him
all this while he he had a family life
and
ballard was wonderful
i'll never forget the day i went to
lunch with him and he was very grim
because balor was in the hospital with
cancer and his
medical benefits had just run out
yeah so she was left to die with cancer
we don't i don't want to be saved like
many times
yeah
she had repaired the house after it had
after the interior had burned
she was great
yeah
then his daughters tried to prevent him
from marrying
karen because they thought he was she
was after his money nothing could
possibly be further from the truth
those were interesting times with a
bunch of very interesting people
yes
anyhow i was just going to say that
engelbart was
an engineer's engineer on several
grounds uh he did publish a paper fairly
early on which
basically articulated
very explicitly what became known as
moore's law
yes now he was not the first uh person
to make that observation
but uh
uh he was
in
his uh the fact he made it for mls
devices
uh
was not widely known
um he um
he worked in a large number of different
areas and
made contributions in each his uh
publications are interesting at uh
in in many different fields
um
so
uh he's
is a uh
uh
a bit of a renaissance uh engineer i
guess in some sense
and uh
you know she
he needs to be appreciated
somebody should bite the bullet and
write a biography about about him but
that hasn't happened yet
maybe that's uh something that you might
attempt
more big projects are not on the horizon
okay
uh is there any other are there any
other questions here
he was norwegian jewish which is
interesting the englewood the engelbart
side
really yeah
okay
yeah i'm sort of a student
i'm sort of a student of
wonderful failed software projects
and xanadu is up there
as one of my
best examples with the transputer maybe
oh the transputer uh the ibm fs project
which had you know a thousand
programmers working on it but
you know i understand why
why systems with a thousand programmers
could fail but somehow
i'm
having trouble understanding why a
system that is is supposedly
conceptually simpler than something
engelbart was doing fewer commands fewer
concepts maybe it had a lot of you know
certainly um
micro payments is not easy to implement
but
um
you know
why
aside from roger and mark
uh
not getting along or
not working well together
why did that project
drag on for so long and then eventually
it was decided to fail
it was owned by autodesk and the name
was owned by autodesk
so after after roger's system
after
i demoted
roger
instead of mark trying to finish what
roger had started he began all over
again
using a
hyper
an extremely intricate system for
automatic
uh version management
devised by eric drexler called the int
which is very hard to find
documented
and so mark was
programming simultaneously in small talk
and then transferring the small talk to
c plus plus
while he was implementing the ant
and he did this for four years
until the web took over and autodesk
killed the project
meanwhile autodesk didn't they have a
a uh micropayment system and an
electronic market
that they had invested in which they
killed after a few years yes that that
that that broke off the xanadu project i
believe
and uh
an auction system and
you know everything that could have been
ebay that turned into ebay
they had and then they squandered it
there's probably a book there along with
fumbling the future
about the failures of autodesk
could well be
i am not one to criticize
but that was that was after john walker
left autodesk i think
right and
carol bartz was the new president
i think that
i wouldn't say that xanadu
[Music]
was a failed project
it was unsuccessful
but it
produced a large number of
extremely interesting ideas
a number of
things
things which have
since later made their way into more
general use
and
so
yeah but i mean if you'd had a vp of
reality that mark don't do that
right you don't have to boil the ocean
in order to write the first line of code
then
maybe it would be on github today and
there would be a thousand people working
on it it might be that
but i think also the other thing mark is
that that the xanadu project
uh
really did differ from from the augment
project the augment project had lots of
little pieces that fit together
whereas the xanadu project had lots of
pieces of data that were supposed to fit
together dynamically yes it was it was a
much more difficult problem well there
was another difference which is augment
had a real customer
which was the darpa network information
center all of those documents that jake
feinler edited
were
written on nls as far as i can tell
and so
so did jake did jake know all those
commands or enough to edit the documents
i think there was a base
you know set of commands that you needed
in order to compose documents and
you know you didn't need to know all of
the
all the 80 or 100 commands more than c
system more than unix system calls i
think
by the way i said i have to get off at
five but i don't have to get it off
until my next appointment arrives and
that could be another hour
so
zigzag you were working on the last time
oh yes i'm very proud of that
uh it's stalled
i'm not proud of my behavior toward my
collaborators i
betrayed them and i feel very ashamed of
that because i said my patent would
would
would
forbid it's being
distributed in the united states and
that was really stupid of me in any case
it works best
on windows xp so if you you can watch it
on youtube
and you can then
buy a used windows xp system on ebay
on which to run it
well two things uh is there
any
analogous
system
any other place
like
ziggs what you intended with zigzag no
zigzag is based upon a mathematical
construct which is
cells connected
in as many dimensions as you like the
only restriction being
that the positive side
of one cell connects to the negative
corresponding negative cell
uh
side of another cell in that particular
dimension
so you can tie up in nuts or create you
could create a regular spreadsheet with
it if you wanted but if you look at the
zigzag movies on youtube
you see some extremely interesting
things done by
especially by adam moore
so a multi-dimensional uh graph
yes
well not exactly a multi-dimensional
graph because
the notion of a dimension there
implies a uniform space
whereas
the dimension in zigzag are is stepping
stones that can be configured any which
way
in a given dimension
so uh exponential space or hyper
dimensional perhaps well i call it hyper
though
yeah that there is no overarching set of
dimensions
well there's certainly not a center
there's not a center and there's not a
space
except unless you unless you call the
construction of cells a space
would the user be considered the center
one well that's that's a that's
you're playing with words there
the user has
in the two in the
versions you can see
the user has two two cursors
one for each hand
and they may be operated independently
in different dimensions
so they can walk around they can join
each other they can meet up and both be
on the same cell or they can wander all
over the lock
and connect things from all over
it's it's it's
truly a fascinating and amazing space i
just wish that uh
is there something that could be
resurrected from it
it exists
it doesn't need to be read or
resurrected you can download it from
xavier.com
and run it on a on a windows xp machine
with of course the appropriate java
there's a link in the chat which will
get you there
yep
thank you
okay
so i have
one small question good it better be
small because my next appointment is
just arriving and when do you want to do
this again
will you uh be interested in chatting
about this i think that just talking
about the
the past history and your perceptions uh
is very interesting and perhaps we can
do it again another time
well but i think that's a nice idea okay
cool think about it
yeah okay we'll we'll we'll negotiate
thank you very much ted thank you
everybody for participating and uh
uh
with this we'll close thank you
bye